this is breaking news
on eight news now
good morning i'm alex jackson breaking
news a murder suicide investigation
leslie's into lieutenant ray spencer
on a shooting investigation near
flamingo and mountain vista the
situation is a hostage
type situation due to the fact that the
male was refusing to let her leave and
she could be hurt
she was heard crying in the background
on the phone
swat made entry into the residence and
found
the male deceased with a self-inflicted
gunshot wound to the head
and also found the female suffering from
a gunshot wound
she was still alive at the time she left
the house the
tactical doctor with the swat team
attempted to render aid they transported
her to
sunrise trauma where she was pronounced
deceased due to the fact that this
is a murder-suicide with officers
outside the residence
we will provide a 72-hour briefing from
our executive staff
within the next three days we are
working diligently to try to open up
flamingo right now
due to the fact swat is now leaving with
hostage negotiators we expect to have
flamingo opened
within the next hour again i'm not
taking any questions this will be
a 72 hour brief will be provided by
executive staff here in the next
three days yes if you're
ever in that situation what's the best
way to make sure that
no one dies like that what was the best
way to
prevent your dream
well the roommate did a roommate did an
absolute phenomenal
thing in this situation she noticed he
was armed with a handgun
and took the child outside of the
residence that is the absolute
smartest thing that she could have done
in this situation so thank you
all right you've been listening to metro
police lieutenant ray spencer giving us
an update
on what we now know as a murder-suicide
happened overnight
around 12 40 this morning near flamingo
and the 95.
we know john this started as a domestic
disturbance inside
we understand that it was between a
husband
and his wife unfortunately they are both
dead this morning